let's get you to your top five takeaways
here rod we'll start you with micah
parsons that was one thing that stood
out from football night in america as
you said right now he's your defensive
player of the year granted that was
before monday night football what is it
that's separating him in your eyes
listen he's a rookie and when you come
in as a rookie your head is spinning
around right you're first of all he's
the first round draft choice so he's
trying to come in and trying to
establish himself in the locker room and
then all of a sudden the first week we
were there in tampa bay what did they do
they threw him at linebacker they threw
him at defensive end he is a rookie and
he's trying to come in and learn one
position and do it extremely well on a
high level but now they have him
learning multiple positions outside
linebacker inside linebacker defensive
ends he's in the a gap mugging he's
dropping back 30 40 yards in coverage i
mean what other player in the national
football league is doing what he's doing
and that's all i'm saying i said it
sunday night but no one's and this kid
is only getting better just think about
the more reps he's getting he's beating
people natural natural athleticism he
runs a 4-3 i mean at 235 40 pounds man
this dude is an absolute animal you
cannot tell i don't care about aaron
donald matthew judon he's been one of
the best
but at the end of the day this is my
defensive player right now now people
are starting to compare him to lawrence
taylor i don't i don't i'm not gonna go
there lawrence taylor was just something
different but this kid is absolutely
special he's humble and he wants to
continue to get better
yeah i don't think you can go there yet
i appreciate you pumping the brakes on
that but but i'm with you and it's not
only right now it's not only currently
in the nfl nobody's doing what he's
doing i'm thinking back a decade i'm
thinking back a couple of decades i
can't think of another name who can play
this many different positions and play
all of them so effectively and what he
does most impressively in my eyes is
that he closes the gap so fast i mean
how many times do you see a quarterback
standing there and parsons has a free
rush at him and before he can even make
a decision whether or not he wants to
juke him out or throw it away or throw
it to some receiver he's getting hit he
closes the gap with that 439 speed and
it's problematic so he's 10th right now
in pressures even though he doesn't rush
nearly as often as most of these pass
rushers fifth and quarterback hits
seventh in sacks he's got 12 to his name
and this may be the most impressive
thing that i saw
25.2 percent win rate as a pass rusher
so over a quarter of his snaps when he's
rushing he wins and that's what it looks
like when you're watching to play
football it's just pure sheer dominance
who else would be in that conversation
with you
around for a while too go ahead what you
got hold on think about the impact on
his teammates cause when you come in as
a young player you have an impact and
guys are raising their level of play
guys are flying around you know guys are
getting better because of micah parsons
because they see his level of
preparation and think about this too dan
when you're playing linebacker when
you're playing defensive end when you're
playing all over the field you got to be
smart you got to be smart you got to be
able to know all the checks all the
adjustments all the games if he's
playing defensive end if it's an e.t uh
n tackles um stunt he has to know that
so he has to know multiple positions and
all the intricacies of that it's very
difficult to do and man and think about
this too offensively if you're an
offense you look and you're trying to
identify well is number 11 is he the mic
or is he the outside linebacker or is he
playing defensive end because he's
moving all over the place so it could it
it constantly causes chaos and confusion
to the offense it's very difficult to
deal with when you got a guy like him
it is and you don't see any of the
others past rushers making as many
tackles as he is that was the other
thing i was looking at they're all in
like the 20s or the 30s maybe the 40s
high end he has 75 tackles this year so
that points to his versatility 17
tackles for lost the only guy i saw
above him on that list was nick rosa so
he's second in the entire group there in
three fourths fumbles so he's just one
of those players that just creates havoc
no matter where you put him he is a
havoc creator and i gotta say i am right
there with you as it currently stands
defensive player of the year although
aaron donald made a heck of a case last
night with those three sacks go ahead
rod
i want i want to ask you a question
because i know everyone's pumping tom
brady up and deservingly so
but do you think we can actually slide a
defensive player over there in that
conversation and could he potentially be
mentioned as the mvp of this league
because to me i think
what we're seeing from tom brady we're
kind of used to seeing
but for him to be a rookie and as bad as
dallas defense was last year as poorly
as they played as inconsistent
inconsistent as they played this guy
single-handedly comes in here and he
just changes the whole tone of this
defense so i'm almost thinking that this
kid is playing so well depending on how
he finishes i think he's going to finish
out great i think you can put him in
that category as possible in vp too
right under brady
i'm with you it's all a matter of
perspective there because once you put
the word value in because then it gets
down to positional value at least in my
opinion in the quarterback position is
so much more valuable than any other
position on the field i mean
quantifiably so that i don't know if i
can make that full push to put him over
the top of a brady or some of these
other great quarterbacks that we've seen
even aaron rodgers playing at an mvp
level here lately i don't know if he's
more valuable
but in terms of what he's done this year
i think he's a perfect fit for defensive
player of the year let's go to your
second on your top five takeaways here
rod which is defense and i think this is
really a cool point by you as these
defenses sort of develop on the fly
throughout the course of the season
that's what we've seen
who are some of these championship
defenses as we're now through 14 weeks
well i have them written down and i'm
going to start with the chiefs i i just
think the chiefs they got to a point
where they had so much success their
offense was so good they got lazy they
took their offense for granted yeah they
had some they had some injuries but
chris jones he has come in and melvin
ingram they've just absolutely just
changed this defense when you're getting
pressure from the exterior from the
outside and the interior and now you're
forcing turnovers tyron matthew he's
been making plays and we saw this we saw
this group a couple times this year
they're starting to fly around they're
starting to trust each other and william
gay middle linebacker his speed has been
just awesome from sideline sideline
it is you're starting to see all the
pieces come together at once i mean i
was looking at what the secondary's been
doing juan thornhill really been playing
well tyron matthew we just talked to him
he's the leader right he's the vocal
leader that's passing all this knowledge
down to the rest of the guys mike hughes
has really been having a good year and
trevarius ward is their other cornerback
who's been playing well then you go to
their nickel rashad fenton he's the
third highest graded nickel defender in
the entire nfl so how many defenses can
you look at that have three premier pass
rushers and five very capable very well
you're very you know playing very well
at the defensive backfield that's a
great combination linebacker is not
exactly the most valuable if you can
crush up front with the pass rush and
the back end that's how you play some
really dangerous defensive football
and a couple more teams that i'm very
familiar with at least the the you know
the coaches i would go with new england
and matthew judon and you said this best
and i remember you saying this on sunday
and i thought this i didn't really
didn't hear this he is the best free
agent of the year he's the best free
agent best free agent pick up of the
year i just think that he's been
outstanding matthew judon definitely
deserves to be in that conversation also
you look into tennessee titans and their
defense has to be good because ryan
taney hills up and down inconsistent
they don't have derek henry they're two
stud wide receivers they're constantly
injured so you don't know what you're
going to get so ryan tannehill needs to
be able to depend on that defense to
help carry him but also this is my last
one the green bay packers i couldn't be
more impressed with the green bay
packers their special teams they need
some work but joe berry came in he
simplified the defense he says look i
don't want to give up big plays
miscommunication errors we're going
gonna simplify the defense we're gonna
let our defensive ends rashaan gary um
defensive tackle kenny clark devondre
campbell that front seven go take over
and they've been phenomenal i mean
devondres campbell he's come in he's
stabilized that defense he's been
awesome for him and he's on only on a
one-year deal he's going to get paid
what about their secondary jack i know
you like this secondary
that's that's a great it's a great great
point rasul douglas nfc defensive player
of the year right he's the first one
that's done that since woodson since
charles woodson for the week of the week
of the week of the week of the week of
the year listen it might as well be at
the year with the pick six he's stacking
up at this point and then you get jair
alexander back imagine that when he
comes back for this team sedarius smith
comes back how about david bachdiori
comes back to help sure up the left side
this is going to be a championship
looking football team isn't it i know we
got one with the bucks but look at the
nfc it's the same two teams green bay
and tampa they're coming together at the
right time
no question and if they're getting
healthy but the big question goes back
to aaron rodgers big toe he comes out he
says oh the big toe is not going to be a
problem but then yesterday he talked
about or the day before he talked about
yesterday how sore it's going to be so
you never know with these turf toes and
things like that but basically their
success on offense is going to come down
to how healthy aaron rodgers feel
well i could talk defensive football all
day we got to spin it back to offense
for your third takeaway from this sunday
which is josh allen you can watch that
game and we've been watching it really
throughout the course of this whole
season man to ask him to do a lot how
much is too much there for josh allen
though ron
yeah i mean i watch the game and he's
he's he's absolutely fantastic when you
see this kid the heart and just how
tough he is and type of hits that he
takes and the type of coverages and the
blitz and the blitzes and all the
different packages but man this dude is
tough as nails he said look forget about
everything else you're not gonna run our
running backs i'm gonna take over i'm
gonna take over this game dawson knox
he's been a huge plus for these guys
coming back big target with soft hands
but josh allen is that dude man and
gabriel davis he's coming along i think
they need to give the ball to gabriel
davis more man when i was out he's a big
dude he's got he's got really good hands
and he loves playing football so um they
need to get back to running the football
i don't know what's going on with brian
dabal i know you have this thud
quarterback but you got to take some
pressure off and alleviate some of that
pressure and run the football at least
try to run a football
it's a it's a great point and they don't
have many awesome options out of the
backfield at running back it's a point
that we've covered but when you look at
the first half of that game here here
was their entire running attack right it
was josh allen
four attempts 43 yards in the first half
not a single receiver or running back
had a carry so it was just josh allen
and when i look at dave ball this was an
okay plan for the big games right for
the big playoff game for the must-have
game to get into the playoffs maybe at
the end of the year maybe for the super
bowl plan but you can't take josh allen
and make him your number one running
option for an 18-week season and then
expect him to get you to the super bowl
on top of that it can't be one design
run after another he's already going to
do enough extending plays scrambling
making plays on his own you can't design
all these plays and have him get all
these extra hits already look at a guy
like lamar jackson he's beat up when the
ravens need him for a playoff push i
just feel like it's way too risky of a
strategy so i don't care if you need to
grab a free agent running back if you
like one of the guys on your practice
squad or on your active roster you have
to start handing them the football or
else josh allen is not going to make it
for the long haul with how talented and
how great that he really is
two things that keeps you keeps you
really actually keeps you from going far
in the playoffs the inability to run the
football and the inability to stop
someone running a football and those are
the two issues that buffalo have you
think about what teams are doing they're
coming in there saying look i'm not
worried about you you soft you got great
quarterback but you're you're a soft
team we're going to run the ball down
your throat the new england patriots
that was a flat out embarrassment that's
why um sean mcdermott he was so upset
because he knew that he got embarrassed
on national television so you got to be
able to stop the run and you have to be
able to run the football to really show
how tough you are
and it was a really impressive come from
behind performance by josh allen to get
him back into this game ultimately to
get this game into overtime but when you
watch the game play out i mean this was
a substantial lead going into halftime
the bucks had it was a substantial lead
even going into the fourth quarter they
had so it took miracle plays to get them
back in it but in reality i think tampa
is a better team than they showed
against buffalo specifically in that
second half it was pretty cool to watch
tom brady go five wide and spread it out
and then before you know it he's got
fournette in there and it's the power
running game it's just the multitude of
different ways that their offense can
attack you and then defensively i
thought they did a better job than
anybody i've seen particularly in the
first half of getting multiple guys
around josh allen if you just get one or
two he can make defensive ends miss he
can stiff arm guys and break tackles but
when you get three or four guys around
him like they were doing you can get
some really big hits in on josh allen
and that seemed to be effective i
thought todd bowles really did a great
job in the first half yet fell apart a
little bit in the second half but todd
bowles very creative with those
pressures in the first half and they
were getting home
yeah and also what he's dealing with is
he's dealing with defenses that are kind
of playing like they're they're playing
patrick mahomes too deep so the one
thing i would say about josh allen if he
can exercise a level of patience when he
sees those two deep safeties and he can
just stay patient and nick and knack
right down the field dink and dunk right
down the field then what happens is
people get tired of that they say you
know what we're tired of that coach it's
like can we play some man can we play
some 3d then all of a sudden you get
those opportunities man-to-man coverage
now you can take your shots down the
field but josh the biggest thing for him
is he has to just show a level of
patience check the ball down and just
truly take what the defense gives them
that's what he needs to do it's a cliche
but it's it's the truth
let's spin you to your fourth take away
we'll keep it with the quarterbacks
we'll keep it with some of the best
offenses and it's green bay we just came
back from green bay for sunday night
football the bears gave them a little
tougher game a little tougher test than
maybe we were thinking going into it
really got out of the gates well did
chicago but i want to focus on the head
coach right and matt lefleur because
they have won a whole bunch of football
games with him there in town he flies a
little under that a-rod radar i
understand that but how valuable really
is he in your mind's eye there ron
i you know what i think i think the one
thing that i see from him
and i see that calming presence i mean
think about i mean to be able to deal
with aaron rodgers on an every single
day basis all right dealing with him in
the meetings in the locker room you're
dealing with such a unique personality
and such as like a such a special person
and he has he has what it takes he has
the demeanor he's calm he's patient he's
open-minded and the fact that he's got
aj dylan and aaron jones rotating
keeping those guys fresh and healthy i
think he's done a great job
his patience level just everything that
he's done
i mean you can almost put him in the
coach of the year situation because i
mean he's dylan he dealt with so much
and he's keeping everything under
control props to matt lafleur man he's
doing a great job
it's a really good point because he
never really gets a ton of credit and
whenever everything is going great aaron
rodgers gets the credit but when things
are going bad he's quick to get the
blame right i mean so he comes in year
one and everybody's going lefleur he's
too young you can't make him the head
coach 13 and three go straight to the
conference championship game and then
they draft jordan love and then you got
rogers going you know four fingers deep
on the whiskey there right so then you
tick off aaron rodgers they come back
the very next year it's a motivated
a-rod he goes to win the mvp 13-3
conference championship game again then
this year you don't even know if aaron
rodgers is going to show up i mean you
have the whole offseason where he's in
hawaii and you don't know he's asking
for a trade who the heck knows if he's
even going to be the quarterback
look where they are ten and three number
one seed right now in the nfc just
overtook the cardinals so i think you
have to give some credit to lefleur and
i think he'd be getting a ton of credit
if he had just been able to clear that
last hurdle but that's what the whole
entire thing comes down to now for the
packers they have been
circling for years now a trip to the
super bowl again for aaron rodgers and
they just have to clear most likely the
tampa bay buccaneers potentially the
rams in order to get back to the super
bowl
yeah think about what matt lafleur did
stepping up changing defensive
coordinators joe berry and give it and
really
giving them stability on the defensive
side of the ball because last year their
defense was so inconsistent giving up
big plays you know um broken coverages
it was just a mess and when he's come in
he's really solidified this defense and
this defense is a defense that can
actually carry and help carry the
offense there's going to be times if
roger's not feeling well where maybe the
offense is stagnant like it was when we
were out there early on and then all of
a sudden now the defense can create a
turnover they can get a couple stops and
that's what you need you need guys like
rasul douglas adrian amos those guys
creating turnovers and making big plays
right and he hires the defensive
coordinator and that's work so you have
to give more credit for the floor there
right
i really like your point too he he does
a good job of balancing
a-rod's ego and a-rod's knowledge that
he's acquired which which is so much
right he knows way more than your
average quarterback but he's given all
of that a little bit of structure and i
think that's that's a delicate balance
and that's an art form so his ability to
do that is pretty darn impressive let's
get to your fifth take away it's a team
that really doesn't have a quarterback
and really doesn't have a solution at
quarterback moving forward at least
doesn't appear that way but kamara is
back for the saints what does he bring
most
man he's bringing a sense of urgency man
he's playing with that energy he's their
best play maker and he was outstanding
whether it's running the ball in between
the tackles or really what he does best
is catching the ball out of the
backfield and everybody they might have
to utilize him a lot more in the passing
game when they playing against tampa bay
coming up this week um this sunday night
so but i like what evelyn kamara has
been doing um i mean obviously he's been
hurt he looks like he's fresh he's got
fresh legs so we'll see if it can
continue because he hasn't met a defense
like this recently that um that he's
going to see like tampa bay
that's right missed four weeks with knee
and hamstring issues let's take a look
at the numbers real quick what the
saints have been doing so this is with
taysom hill and with alvin kamara so
look at those touches right there for
kamara taysom hill right taysom hill's
not going to be somebody like brady
who's going to drop back and beat you
with 30 pass attempts a game so he's
going to need a camaro type we can just
dump the ball down to he's gonna need a
strong running game if they're gonna
have any chance i they are gonna have a
serious headache on their hands heading
into tampa with the team who's gonna be
ticked off that they just let the
buffalo bills back into that game late
to go into overtime
yeah you better expect you know the game
plan from todd bozes he's going to load
that box he's going to make sure that
they don't get off you know running the
football and they're going to try to
make taysom hill beat him make him
one-dimensional tight man-to-man
coverage force taste some hill to throw
in those tight windows that's what you
want to do and i'll tell you when he's
running around he's going to get a big
taste of levante david
you know devon white those guys man they
fly around they're big they're thick
just like him i can't wait to see it but
he's jason hill is going to have to drop
back and make some passes he can't just
run his way to a victory against the
tampa bay buccaneers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports